According to countless movies and TV shows,
sea captains, in addition to getting to wear
dapper uniforms and snazzy hats, have the
ability to marry couples aboard their ships
thanks to the power bestowed upon them by…
the sea we guess?
So can these captains actually perform marriages
that are then legally binding?
As in most things in life, particularly when
the law is involved, it’s complicated.
However, as a general rule, with a few exceptions
like Japan, Bermuda, and Romania, sea captains
do not have any inherent authority to officiate
weddings where the couple will then be considered
legally married.
(Japanese sea captains are given such authority,
as long as they’re marrying two people who
are also Japanese, and a similar thing is
true in Romania, where interestingly Romanian
law also gives aircraft captains the same
power.
Bermuda allows ship captains this same privilege,
so long as the ship they’re captaining is
registered in Bermuda.
This was a not too subtle way to get more
cruise ships to register their boats in Bermuda-
and it totally worked, by the way.)
Despite this sort of authority not really
being a thing in most regions, it is entirely
possible, and not even terribly uncommon,
for sea captains to marry couples.
For example, one Captain Arnold Wonsever,
working for Skyline Cruises in New York, noted
he performs on average close to 200 weddings
per year.
So how do all those sea captains who currently
do it get around the legality problem, and
where did the ubiquitous idea that such individuals
had that authority come from in the first
place?
To begin with, because there is such a common
notion worldwide that sea captains are able
to officiate legally binding marriages, some
sea captains choose to go get the extra certification
they’d need to do so.
It’s simply a great way to make a little
side money while otherwise performing their
day job of captaining the ship.
It’s also in some cases a way to get more
people to come aboard your ship in the form
of wedding parties.
Getting such certification isn’t difficult
in many regions, such as in the United States
where becoming ordained is absurdly easy,
with various organizations offering this service
online, in a few cases even for free.
Moving beyond the certified, some sea captains
will simply officiate a wedding ceremony,
but with it understood that said individual
does not have the ability to sign off on things
to make the marriage legally binding.
However, there is even a caveat here in that,
depending on where you’re from, it may be
the case that declaring in front of witnesses
that you’re marrying someone that you also
then go and live with can qualify you for
a common law marriage.
And, contrary to popular belief, it’s often
not required that you live with the person
for several years before said common law marriage
kicks in.
In some places, it’s instant.
In this case, it wouldn’t matter if you
had the guy who swabs the decks, or even a
literal bilge rat, perform the ceremony.
It could still be legally binding if you wanted
it to be.
And, pro-tip- the bilge rat’s probably way
cheaper than getting the captain to do it.
For all other cases where the captain has
no legal authority here, the individuals getting
married will typically just go get married
officially in front of a judge or minister
somewhere else either before or after their
wedding at sea.
In fact, aboard some cruise ships where the
sea captain isn’t certified to officially
marry a couple, but said company offers some
sort of wedding service package, the company
will simply have an individual on board who
does have the required certification.
This way the couple gets the sea captain wedding
ceremony they wanted, and the legally binding
side of things as well all in one place.
This all brings us around to the question
of how this widely accepted trope came about.
Well, nobody knows for sure…
But the general thought is that, as traveling
across the big blue was once a rather time
consuming process and potentially done with
many people packed aboard off to start new
lives, there was sometimes desire for marriage
while on the trip.
Now with the occasional need established,
it’s also noteworthy that sea captains once
had near absolute authority over the vessels
they commanded.
For example, captains from many regions historically
had the authority to do things like arrest
and jail those aboard their ships, create
birth and death certificates, more or less
function as a notary for official documents
like wills, and even in some cases were required
to note in their logs when weddings occurred
aboard their ship.
Thus, it’s hypothesized that these types
of extra powers, particularly officially logging
marriages that happen on the ship and then
later reporting them to authorities, all perhaps
gave the general public the idea that captains
could legally marry couples.
And, for whatever reason, sea captains seem
to have been happy to oblige such requests.
In an apparent attempt to get their captains
to stop doing this, at least in the US Navy,
in the early 20th century they included a
section tucked away in the Code of Regulations
dealing with this very phenomenon –
The commanding officer shall not perform a
marriage ceremony on board his ship or aircraft.
He shall not permit a marriage ceremony to
be performed on board when the ship or aircraft
is outside the territory of the United States.
According to the regulations, the only time
such marriages are allowed is if a registered
official who can perform a legally binding
marriage is aboard the ship or plane and all
relevant permits and permissions in accordance
with local laws of the couple being married
have been obtained.
Outside of that, however, the first sentence
forbids captains from performing the ceremony,
and the second sentence forbids them from
allowing others to do it when at sea, presumably
owing to the legal complication that arises
from marrying people when out in international
waters.
But to sum all this up- no, as a general rule,
outside of the caveats previously mentioned,
sea captains do not have the authority to
legally marry a couple.
This, however, has not stopped them from performing
such ceremonies, nor Hollywood from promoting
the idea that they do have this power.
This has all resulted in an almost world-wide
notion today that sea captains are able to
do this, in turn resulting in some captains
getting additional certification to be able
to marry couples looking for a sea based wedding
performed by someone in a snazzy uniform.
The culmination of all of this has even resulted
in places like Japan and Romania granting
their sea captains this ability.
And in recent years there’s even been a
push by shipping unions in the UK to likewise
give sea captains this ability without having
to jump through an extra hoop of getting
outside certification.